[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Sallys
Welt heute mache ich einen Muttertags
eine Muttertags genau okay ich schaffe
das warte ich muss kurz durchgehen
okay ich glaube ich mach's ich schaffe
es
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Sallys
Welt heute mache ich eine
muttertagstorte für meine Mama und zwar
ein naked cake für meine geliebte
geliebte Mama
[Musik]
tut mir leid
ich mache jetzt erstmal den Biskuit und
dafür benötigt ihr vier Eier 100 g
Zucker eine Prise Salz etwas
Vanilleextrakt und 100 g backmehl falls
Sie kein back mir zu Hause habt das sehr
böse dann braucht ihr nur 100 g Mehl und
ein Teelöffel Backpulver zuerst gebe ich
die Eier mit dem Salz und dem Zucker und
den Vanilleextrakt in eine Schüssel und
rührst für 15 bis 20 Minuten cremig
[Musik]
habe ich das jetzt 20 Minuten rühren
lassen
oh ich habe es hinbekommen und jetzt
habe ich vorsicht das ist mir vorsichtig
das ist
[Musik]
für die quark-sahnecreme benötigt ihr
400 g Sahne etwas sanaparte zum steif
schlagen 500g Quark 70 g Puderzucker und
ein Teelöffel Vanilleextrakt während die
Böden Abkühlen mache ich schon mal meine
Sahne Quarkcreme und dafür gebe ich
jetzt erstmal mein Quark in eine Schale
in eine Schüssel
und dann gebe ich noch Puderzucker und
ein bisschen Vanille
Wasser zusammen cremig
[Musik]
und jetzt noch ein bisschen Sahne
jetzt ist mein Boden ausgekühlt und
jetzt werde ich es auch in drei Teile
schneiden um es dann am Ende zu befüllen
und dann könnt ihr eigentlich auch drauf
machen was ihr wollt ich nehme jetzt zum
Beispiel Erdbeeren und Blaubeeren und
Himbeeren und dann nehme ich noch ein
paar
schokoladencrips
und dann nehme ich noch ein bisschen
Marmelade und ihr könnt eigentlich
generell so gestalten
[Musik]
eventuellerweise mein Smiley der ist so
hübsch geworden hier mein Smiley Herz
hier so ein bisschen so muss natürlich
aussehen also schon aber so sieht's halt
hübsch aus wenn man so ganz glatt machen
ich glaube das ist so der Sinn von naked
cake
[Musik]
ich habe gerade eben vergessen
die Früchte in die Torte rein zu machen
egal geht auch so
so wir lieben Erdbeeren deswegen nehmen
wir ganz viel Erdbeer
und weil wir blaubei nicht mögen nehmen
wir nur dieselbauer werden damit es
schön aussieht und jetzt nehmen wir noch
Minze und damit es gut riecht was am
Ende wahrscheinlich
gehen kann Unterschied machen und wieso
wow
ja richtig gut
[Musik]
jetzt ist die Torte auch schon fertig
und meine mama darf kommt zum Probieren
kommst du ja
die sieht so so so so wunder wunderschön
aus die ist richtig toll wenn sie doch
so toll aussehen dann müssen wir auch
mal schauen ob sie toll schmeckt ja das
machen wir die ist so schön ich glaube
da freut sich einfach jede Mama über so
eine Torte wenn die Tochter der Sohn
egal wer eine Torte für sie backt sieht
richtig teuer ein kleines Stück
oder
schön und die Creme das ist eine
quarksahne Creme
mag ich sehr wow mit Fruchtfüllung
wow die sieht super aus schön
pummeluft
drin ja also das ist ein Biskuitboden
und ähm das ist eben diese quark-sahne
Creme und das eben noch Erdbeermarmelade
und eben
danke mein Schatz da kommt ja noch ein
Muttertagsgeschenk komm
ich finde
zum Muttertag muss man nichts
verschenken man sollte einfach nur Zeit
mit seiner Mama verbringen wenn man sie
noch hat und mit ihr schöne Stunden
genießen
Ella und Samira ja
und ihr seid das Wichtigste das aller
aller Wichtigste in meinem Leben
deswegen bin ich ganz glücklich mit euch
hier sind ganz viele
und ihr dürft das Rezept gerne
nachbacken ach was übernehme Video ja
ihr könnt diese Rezepte nach backen und
das Rezept findet ihr auf
wahrscheinlich bald.de
Muttertagsgeschenk an mich dass ich
jetzt in Rente gehen kann ja okay und
Samira übernimmt alles ja
viel Spaß beim Nachbacken viel Spaß
gemacht
ja
wunder wunderschön
[Musik]